it's 1988 my mom is staring at a roomful
of people will decide the future of my
two older sisters my parents had been
told that their daughters would not be
allowed to enroll in the local
neighborhood elementary school instead
they would be shipped to a segregated
classroom for children with disabilities
two cities away my mom is furious she
argues that if the children of our
neighbors and friends attend the local
public school that her daughter's should
too the school board members speak at
length using lots of words about
logistics and capacity and cost to words
they never use are my sister's names
Sarah and Alison there were a lot of
meetings like this over the years of my
childhood Sarah Nelson both have severe
developmental disabilities and my
parents advocated tirelessly on their
behalf working with institutions ranging
from schools to health providers and
state agencies and I remember that there
was a clear difference between the
organizations that treated our family
like whole real complex human beings and
those that didn't most of us can
remember a time when we felt dehumanized
by an experience within a system maybe
you're thinking of your last interaction
with a customer service hotline or the
DMV yeah perhaps you're remembering a
tough navigation of the healthcare
system or an employer who made you feel
like a faceless number I am fascinated
by the question of what it means to
treat people like real people what it
looks like to offer the dignity risk
fact and compassion that we all crave in
our interactions and I'm especially
interested in how we as leaders can
create organizations that do just that
the treat people like real people I
believe it comes down to designing our
systems specifically and intentionally
for empathy so why is it important for
us to learn how to build empathy into
our organizations well I hope that all
of you have experienced the impact of
human kindness within a system for me I
think about the ER nurse last year who
long after midnight on one of the worst
nights of my life brought coffee and
snacks to the bedside where I sat with a
sick family member it turns out that
experiences of compassion like this one
have extremely real consequences for our
health research right here at Stanford
has shown that patients who receive
human kindness and empathy during their
treatment experience faster healing of
wounds reduced pain anxiety and blood
pressure and shorter hospital stays but
treating people like real people isn't
just important in the health sector
humans are evolutionarily wired with
what UC Berkeley researchers have coined
the compassion instinct we are driven to
empathize with the feelings of others
and to give and seek aid both engaging
in and receiving acts of compassion
results in physiological and
psychological benefits and quite simply
make for happier people so if we are
evolutionarily wired to be compassionate
toward one another why is it that so
many of us feel dehumanized by the
systems and organizations in our lives
well when I asked people what made them
feel human the most common
sponses were I feel like a real person
when people care about my background in
history when they listen to and know and
acknowledge my story people will tell
you I am NOT my disability I am NOT my
leukemia I am not my SAT score I am not
my depression I am not my immigration
status I am not my gender I am NOT this
singular interaction with you after all
we all contain multitudes I believe that
our organizations fail when they are not
designed and led to acknowledge these
multitudes empathy is what allows us in
our one-on-one interactions to treat
each other like real people to
understand that there is a full story
behind everyone we meet so what we need
for our organizations is a way to
systematize human empathy to do this I
suggest starting with three simple rules
listen contextualize and cultivate to
systematize empathy an organization has
to start by identifying its ears what
mechanisms does the organization use to
listen to its stakeholders
organizational listening can't just be
about a feedback box in the corner we
have to give stakeholders a valid place
at the table as respected partners an
example in practice right here in the
Bay Area juvenile justice systems are
working with the organization fresh
lifelines for youth to develop
mechanisms to listen to youth voices
these partnerships are helping to reduce
recidivism and educating the justice
system
on how to better serve its community the
second rule of building empathetic
organizations is operating with a
holistic appreciation for context when I
was working with healthcare
organizations in East Africa some of the
most effective models I saw were those
that have dressed issues intersecting
with patients health from nutrition and
sanitation to education and employment
these organizations approach their
patients as whole multifaceted people
and their medical outcomes were the
better for it
finally to cultivate empathy
organizations must unlock their most
powerful asset their own employees
research shows that stress burnout and
toxic company culture can squash our
compassion instinct but findings suggest
that companies that form a culture of
compassion not only boost employee
happiness and health they also improve
their bottom lines plus compassion is
proven to be contagious so if we want
our clients and customers to be treated
well we have to start by treating our
teammates like real whole people - back
in 1988 my mom told that school board
that if they didn't let her daughter's
into school she would sit with them on
the front lawn of Magnolia elementary
every single day until they did well
great job mom my parents ultimately won
their fight Seren Allison entered
Magnolia elementary school and
eventually Allison became our County's
first fully mainstreamed student with
disabilities to graduate from high
school my mom is very clear about one
important fact from our family's journey
it was not until there was organization
reform in districts and schools then my
sisters were truly treated like real
people so it's time for all of us to own
the fact that individual acts of
kindness are not enough it is time for
us to take organizational empathy out of
the realm of the random out of the realm
of above and beyond
and into the realm of the expected thank
you